this vague notion of progress that he
sets up where nobody really knows
everybody knows that they're being on
the right side of history and everybody
knows that they're working towards the
the this great Progressive thing but
nobody knows what it is and it's like
that's still like that today you look
around us and we notice people talking
about progress and being Progressive and
you know this is the future and but if
you ask them what that means they just
stare at you blankly because they have
no idea where it is that they're
heading
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
World hello everyone I am speaking with
Annie Crawford Annie is a scholar who
has studied CS Lewis she teaches baywolf
she teaches all these things in
classical high school she's also written
quite a bit and uh and she is going to
head up a class on CS Lewis and The
Ransom Trilogy for us something that
I've also read recently you know it
seems to be kind of in the air
everybody's talking about it everybody
is buzzing around it because it seems
like it points to a lot of things that
are happening now in terms of let say
the shape of the world but also in terms
of the re-enchantment and a return of of
of more Cosmic thinking and she recently
wrote an article for us uh on gender and
cosmology about CS Lewis which you can
check out on the symbolic world uh blog
and so Andy I'll let you also introduce
yourself and tell us a little bit about
your background and what sparked this
class that you're going to give for us
yeah hi Jonathan thanks for having me so
I'm from Austin Texas and I have
homeschooled my three daughters and I
think I've always been interested in CS
Lewis very much he played an important
role in my own Journey
um toward coming to understand the world
and what it means to be human and as
I've homeschooled my girls we've just
been learning together diving deeper
deeper into the tradition and uh then as
I'm educating them seeking around me who
else we can invite into this work of um
integrating education and discipleship
and Reviving uh what I call a
sacramental understanding of the world
and so um when the girls were older and
I had a little bit more time I continued
my studies formally by working on a a
degree in cultural apologetics at
Houston Christian University which that
degree really focuses on the work of CS
Lewis CS Lewis is really seen as a
founder of a new approach to apologetics
a new approach to helping people
understand uh not just having Arguments
for um certain beliefs but offering
helping make
uh the Christian view of the world
meaningful um helping people understand
the meaning of it and as I
um have been doing that work I found
your work at the symbolic um world and
really feel that what you're doing and
what CS Lewis was trying to do are very
complimentary and so you know in the
symbolic World community on
Circle uh people were just discussing as
you said Lewis is in the air The Ransom
Trilogy especially post 2020 there seems
to be a lot more attention being drawn
towards the ransom Trilogy and so in the
symbolic World Community there was just
interest in you know discussing these
books in depth there's a real hunger um
it to at the symbolic World Community is
really a phenomenal group of people from
all over the world people who are uh
eager insightful thoughtful
reflective um and so
I thought well let's just get together
and let's study C Lewis together and
there was so much interest and such a
desire for depth that it really became a
class and so as you were launching the
new bolf class we thought let's make
this an official class and really dive
in deep together to study these
important books which I really think
have been given to us for such a time as
this I also read The Ransom Trilogy
recently and I was really struck um
especially uh That Hideous Strength of
just how much Insight Lewis seemed to
have had about where the world was going
you know and also this this strange
organization that he sets up this kind
of evil secret organization there's
something about it which rings so true
about things that we're seeing in the
culture now first of all in in some ways
this vague notion of progress that he
sets up where nobody really knows
everybody knows that they're being on
the right side of history and everybody
knows that they're working towards the
the this great Progressive thing but
nobody knows what it is and it's like
that's still like that today you look
around us and we notice people talking
about progress and being Progressive and
you know this is the future and but if
you ask them what that means they they
they just stare at you blankly because
they have no idea where it is that
they're heading yeah well it really is a
retelling of the Tower of Babel which
you've done several videos on and what
strikes me in what you're saying is I
see the Tower of Babel as our attempt to
gather up meaning and reach into the
heavens but if we're not properly
receiving meaning from above then our
efforts to to reach up with our own
meaning are going to be aimless they're
not going to be a clear tellos or a
clear aim because we are seeking
independently to do that from the bottom
up so that sense of you know we're going
somewhere who knows exactly where uh I
think is very much part of the meaning
of the Tower of Babel Motif yeah and
there's the the whole idea of the head
in the the by the way there this is
going to be full of spoilers so if you
don't want spoilers don't watch it but
we're not gonna we're not going to be
careful about the spoilers so you should
have read it anyways by now so this
whole idea of this head right this kind
of disembodied head that is the head of
their that organization this like
massive brain you know it's really
interesting to see how you know this was
written one in the 40s is that when it
was written yeah so in the 1940s having
this insight about what really for us
would would be Ai and you know this idea
of this disembodied intelligence and
also the tendency to worship it right
and the tendency to to create a god
there's some of the some of the
dialogues that are so close to what the
transhumanists are saying now this idea
that we're going to make a God you know
we've heard that recently from the head
of of Google in that interview with Elon
Musk where he said we're going to build
a God it's like everything you believed
in the past it's it wasn't true back
then but we're going to make it true you
know by creating this perfect this like
weird perfect intelligence and also this
joining of humanity into into this he
doesn't use the word Singularity but it
feels like that's what he's he's kind of
pointing to uh yeah I mean his Insight
is is is phenomenal um so I let's look
at the gender question because that's
one of the things I was really happy to
see your article because I was struck by
a a sentence in the text and I tweeted
it at some point where uh CS Lewis says
gender is more primordial than sex or
something like that like gender precedes
sex and that's something that modern
people like even modern conservatives
were getting annoyed with me because
they want to collapse gender and sex
together but csis doesn't do that at all
so maybe tell us a bit about this idea
of gender and how CS treats it as a
cosmic Force yeah and I think you know
how you're saying that even
conservatives get confused I think that
shows us how much the sacred view of the
world really has been lost that even
people who say they believe in God
really are functional materialists in
many way or functional dualists they
don't understand how Heaven and Earth
fit together because um that knowledge
that cultural knowledge has been lost um
so I have the quote right here that
you're talking about from CS Lewis and I
think this is from paralandra he says
gender is a more fun m al reality than
sex sex is in fact merely the adaptation
to organic life of a fundamental
polarity that's key fundamental polarity
which divides all created beings and so
it's not that hard to understand if you
recover even the materialist should be
able to understand it it's not it's
actually not like a woo woo statement at
all in any ways right well you
know sometimes what we want to see
blinds us from seeing what is there
right so you know if you have a um
symbolic view of the world or a
sacramental view of the world or even a
pagan view of you the world you know
that the fundamental polarity is heaven
and earth right in the beginning God
created the heavens and the Earth and
you know you talk about this all the
time in your work that the heavens being
the realm you could see think of it as
like St Paul says in Colossians
invisible invisible the realm of meaning
the realm of form that's the heaven
um that is made to fit with and be
manifest within the Earth that the
fundamental structure of reality is a
marriage between Heaven and Earth where
God uh you know is spirit and he is
prior he uh is the logos who
speaks the world the cosmic Mountain
into being and that is as as Lewis is
saying the fundamental polarity
that forms all things and that is
repeated in all things in that fractal
level that fractal repetition right and
so sex is the biological adaptation the
the bi the fractal repetition of that
Cosmic polarity played out on the
physical level and you know and I think
sometimes what people um again get
concerned about is the way that that um
there's a a false polarity a false
dualism um talked about in our culture
right where we say well if we separate
gender and
sex then we're separating the meaning in
a way that makes them arbitrary and
that's what I think people get concerned
about but but if you understand that
even the on the cosmic level that LS is
talking about it's still has to do with
generation gender has to do with Genesis
genitals generation it's still the mode
in which life is created reality is
beeded and so that even if we
acknowledge the cosmic level of gender
as somewhat different from the physical
level of sex still the connection is not
arbitrary yeah I think that's the
biggest thing this is something that I I
talked about with uh with Richard rley
in our last discussion which is that the
this is really where you see how people
struggle to understand a basic symbolic
understanding of reality which is that
just because there are different levels
of of a pattern doesn't mean that those
are free floating and that so if you
separate sex and gender doesn't mean
that now sex can be one thing and gender
can be the other it's like no it's
actually a connection of different
levels of participation in the same
pattern um and even if for example let's
say the Customs that we have about how
to dress as man or woman how men present
present themselves even though that's
variable across cultures first of all
it's not infinitely variable that's
nonsense it's it has it's variable to
some extent and but then even though
it's variable the polarity still is
universal that is you know for example
like there are cultures where men
ornament themselves and women ornament
themselves less let's say and and that's
something in our culture which is the
opposite but in that culture men
ornament themselves and women don't and
the polarity is still present and and
there's still this sense of this is how
men act this is how women act and This
Is How They Come Together uh and it's
not like I said and it's also not um
it's never free floating and arbitrary
it's never like it could be anything and
that's it's difficult for people to
understand that but that's you know it's
like we believe that all the time like
we think that there are different
species of dogs but we nonetheless
recognize that you know this species of
dog and this other species of dog is
still a dog even though there's
variation in the species but for some
reason with humans if we see that it's
like we feel like our whole world is
threatened or that it's going to blow
all the categories but variation and
pattern is just how it actually how it
functions in terms of uh in terms
especially in terms of cultural cultural
participation yeah tell us a bit about
about how CS Le represents it because he
I mean I think it's a little scandalous
the way he does because he literally
uses pagan gods as his image
to represent this yeah it is scandalous
and a lot of people criticize Lewis um
even Christians for being misogynistic
in the way that he portrays gender and I
think that's part of what calls me to
this topic um especially as a woman I I
do feel like perhaps it's a little less
scandalous if maybe I talk about it but
um so in terms of him using Venus
goodness there's so many directions we
could go
um let's talk a little bit maybe about
his world viw the bigger picture that
then we can situate the discussion of
gender in so Lewis has what he would
call what I call a sacramental worldview
which I do think is synonymous to what
you talk talk about with a symbolic
worldview because it really is this idea
that what what re visible reality is is
a manifestation of visible spiritual
form right um and a symbol is a is a
locust where uh meaning from Heaven
comes and is embodied within h a visible
form and that's the same as a
sacramental worldview Sacrament means um
a visible sign of an invisible reality
and I think um some people get confused
about Sacrament because you think well
no a Sacrament is a baptism or or some
kind of particular religious
point of contact Between Heaven and
Earth but I think one way that's helpful
to be clear on this is to separate
between what the two books that the
tradition would call the um General
Revelation the book of nature the
meaning that is spoken throughout all
creation and invisible to all men and
then special Revelation um where Heaven
meets Earth in particular ways uh Christ
the church Eucharist baptism but but
they're just different levels of the
same thing right of Heaven being
manifested on Earth and I think this can
help us understand Lewis's um love of
the Pagan and that he that that the
Pagan world had access to General
Revelation just like everyone else and
pagans could read the meaning of the
world through the things that are made
and Romans 1 makes this clear within
scripture that that the the the nature
of Heaven of the Divine is evident
through the things that he's made and so
you know the pagans looking at the
cosmos at gender masculinity femininity
they're going to be able to see deep
fundamental spiritual truth through
General Revelation and but you know
being cut off from cast out of Eden um
and you know perhaps under the rule of
suspect uh Rebels from the Divine
Council right you want to go so that the
Pagan tradition is going to be a mix of
Truth and
Distortion um and so that's going to be
Lewis's view of of the Pagan world and
what he wants to do is is say we can and
and this is what the church fathers did
when Jerusalem met Athens right this is
what Justin mardar did is we're going to
sort
through the The Inheritance the insights
from Rome from Greece and sort through
and and take out what is true and what
is good and that's going to be the way
that we transpose
translate um the the Christian special
Revelation that has been seen so that's
just what Lewis is doing in his
portrayal of gender he's saying let's
look at the cosmos let's look at the
tradition and let's use that as a as a
way of translating helping us in a
modern age uh understand what sex and
gender is is um so that's kind of the
framework in which he investigates this
theme um where would you like to go from
there do you want to talk about the
gender structure of the book no so yeah
we can we can talk a little bit I mean
what interests me is also how he he
structured the two books you know the
two first books as basically this kind
of male world and this this this female
world and then how he culminates it into
the figures of these angels
which ultimately reveal themselves to be
a kind of purified version of what the
ancient gods were in some ways his take
on it is is quite strong which is that
he seems he says something like the
version of Mars and Venus that we have
on earth have been Twisted by by the
evil one and because our own let's say
angel has Twisted all these these
stories and twisted all these images but
there is in some ways a fined version of
these so it's not like he's saying it's
this is why I'm saying it's scandalous
in the sense that he's not saying
there's Mars and then there's St Michael
right they say that's the way that I
would more tend to have a I would tend
to do it myself I would say there's St
Michael and there's Mars and St Michael
is the true Marshall Spirit and the the
the the one that is aligned with God
Mars was a kind of Twisted version of it
but what what CS Le does he basically
makes it the same figure he says there
is Mars and Mars is an angel that that
that worships God and the version that
we get on Earth is Twisted by the devil
that's what I that's what I find I find
it interesting because I feel like you
know I'm I'm I'm impressed at how far
he's willing to go despite being a very
Orthodox small o Orthodox Christian and
everybody seeing him as as you know
someone who is a apologetics person for
for Christianity even to so I don't know
if you had any thoughts on that yeah I I
do think it's important to remember that
CS Lewis is not a saint and he's not
right about
everything and
that you know and I was listening to
your talk on subtle bodies actually and
thinking about that and so sometimes
it's hard to tell what Lewis is doing
for the sake of story for the sake of um
well this is one way to portray it
within a a subc created world and when
he trying when he's maybe proposing that
he really thinks this right so that
would be to me the question of how how
are we then in Lewis's cosmology to fit
together an understanding of St Michael
and Mars and it's so it's hard for me to
know where sometimes he's
been um using tropes and images for the
sake of the story and where he's really
maybe experimentally
exploring what he thinks you know a real
cosm
and one thing that concerns me about um
some of the things he says is he plays
with the idea of maybe there's seven
genders or there's you know he he just
loved the medieval model so much and and
he got I feel like he would get so
excited about these um symbolic
structures that you know there's the
seven planets um and if two of them are
gender then you know maybe are there
seven genders and should we understand
gender in some kind of bigger way
there's um a dialogue called unreal
Estates where he's kind of talking about
science fiction with two other friends
and in it he says has anyone
successfully portrayed three genders in
their fiction yet and those things to me
are red flags they concern me because I
really do think because of what's going
on now well yeah that you know in terms
of the the just chaotic loosening yeah
of gender category
and the fact that
well what gender is is is a fractual
representation of Heaven and Earth I
mean you don't get that's the
fundamental relationship between God and
His creation between Creator and
creation between Christ and his bride
there is a fundamental
Duality yeah and and to to say well
maybe The Duality is Sevenfold I I think
is really dangerous it's dangerous well
you might be surprised to find out that
for example Sam maith the Confessor uh
who I I I talk about a lot he he talks
about three genders in the way he talks
about it he he says there's masculine
feminine and something which you could
characterize as I think he uses the term
extreme uh and the idea is that there's
something something like masculine
feminine and
exceptional and in his third gender he
puts uh that which is above and that
which is below so B basically Unix are
the are third gender in the loose way
that you understand gender understand
unic which is like anybody who doesn't
really fit it's like whether something
happened to them or they're born weird
or whatever it is like whoever doesn't
totally fit is like is is a is that but
then there's also this the the monk the
monk is a third gender because he's not
engaged in uh in sexuality and is there
is trying to transcend gender so it's
actually trying to interpret Christ's
very strange text which is yeah he says
there are Unix that are accidentally
Unix and there are Unix that are Unix
that that I think like for the glory of
God or something like that right so I
would say that that's
probably I I prefer that structure
myself because one of the problems with
absolute
Duality is that there really are things
that don't fit like they just are and so
you don't you you struggle if you if you
don't have a category for the monster or
the exception or the king or something
which is beyond the normal structure of
of a of kind of of Duality then you um
then you you run into problems and you
try and you try to make the work the
world perfect you know so I I would say
the best way to see it at least for me
is to understand that there are three
genders and that the third gender is is
undefinable you could say is not is is
is the exception is the is the thing
that doesn't fit in the normal uh right
the normal categories anyway can I can I
try to to maybe resolve that I do feel
like
saying three genders is going to be
confusing particular in our context um
but I do think there's a way to fit in
the third category so let me let me try
and like sketch this out because if you
think of gender again as meaning Genesis
the way in which we generate new life I
mean that what it is Heaven and Earth
meet right and then uh that we gets new
life on a fractal level right so you
have Adam and
Eve man and woman they participate in a
certain way with the generation of new
life and that new life itself is a
fractal representation of heaven and
earth right um so the reserving gender
for that language for the way in which
new life is generated right and so if
you have someone who doesn't fit that
Duality let's
say I feel like calling it a third
gender well I can see how from some
perspective but one is there's in in
this world there is discology there is
the effect of the Fall there is the lack
of function right and um and so people
who don't fit uh because of something
gone wrong
um that's one particular category and
it's really important to to be willing
to acknowledge that because it's by
recognizing a
discology that we can then in love and
care seek to restore to proper order
right so if someone we is born without
let's say an arm or a leg we recognize
that as dis
function and form of what it is to be
human and by recognizing that that's how
we know to care about that person and to
help um supplement to restore them to
the fullness of order as much as we can
um but then I think there's also so one
way people don't fit The Duality or that
category is because of the Fall because
of of discology but another way they
don't fit is because of of transcending
to another level yeah right and so I
think that
and this might be the monk this would be
the unic this would be the person who's
going to transcend that generative
Duality on the biological level because
they're going to participate in it on a
higher level right the that they're
going to more fully and directly
participate in the marriage between
Heaven and Earth that's going to
generate new spiritual
life um and so I think that's another
way those who don't fit so there's the
dis teologico and then there's those who
transcend who kind of move up a fractal
level to a different uh meeting of
Heaven and Earth and I just hesitate to
like call that a third they're all the
same no and I think you're absolutely
right that it's wrong it's it's a it's
dangerous to just it's dangerous to not
to be able to distinguish in that
category between that which is which
transcends transcends above and that
which falls out below uh and I think
you're right I say that all the time
right I talk about this too it's like
you know in in scripture there's the
separation of waters there's the waters
above and the waters below ultimately
they come from the same Source but in
reality like in practice they're not
like they they are the Opposites you
know you the water that is below is Mara
and bitter and the water that comes from
above is sweet and is you know and is
and is let's say consumable and so I I
totally agree with you but but just so
you know that that it is the idea that
there are three genders is something
which is not completely alien of of
Christianity that it's there you know uh
and trying to figure out how to deal
with that that problem of some people
transcending above and then like you
said some people kind of falling out uh
from from below um so so so back to to
to CS Lewis he he ends up presenting in
That Hideous Strength like the end of
Hideous Strength is almost like
a it's almost like a caricature like the
way that it ends and that it's like
everybody gets married like everybody
gets you know everybody gets married
even the animals and everybody is like
getting everybody is is is uni uni
unifying Heaven and Earth uh you know I
was actually I I'd read it a long time
ago but I reread it like a month ago and
I was just surprised at just how much he
put in there like just how how far he
was willing to go in his in his analogy
well you know it's like a Shakespeare
play on steroids that's right yeah
that's what you know it's a tragedy if
everyone dies and you know it's a comedy
if everyone gets married even the
animals yeah and he was very he seemed
very conscious about that like he was
very conscious that he was in some ways
pushing the pushing the limit because
you can hear the animals and everybody
is is like is H is getting married so
yeah but but you do you do have a
representation of that um person who
transcends the
physical you the level of sex right
because Ransom himself is in a sense a
unic or a monk or a Mystic so you do
have I mean the key character uh in a
sense the hero who himself
transcends that Duality on the material
or physical familial level in in order
to participate on the Heavenly level and
and he literally is ascends into heaven
at the end of the book yeah and it's
important also to explain that in a way
that also helps people understand how
you transcend which is that he doesn't
transcend his gender by becoming
confused that he doesn't he doesn't
manifest confused gender in fact he
manifests a refined version of gender a
kind of hyper gender where he becomes a
kind of hyper masculine not in the
ridiculous way that we think of that on
YouTube now but in some ways he becomes
a kind of purified version of of a man
you know and there's even that scene
where the the I forget the name of the
characters but the the woman the the
wife you know she's attracted to them
and it's like but she's attracted to him
in a in a strange way where in some ways
it's almost like it doesn't make her
want to sleep with him or anything but
she's attracted to him in a way that
makes her think of her husband
ultimately like kind of brings her back
to her husband but he becomes like this
model of masculinity that reminds her
you know that she's a woman let's say
like something like that and and that's
also I think the way that even in terms
of monastics you see that in in the
monastic life there isn't this sense of
like confused gender but but rather the
monks become very masculine you know and
they they kind of have a they have a
beard and they have a kind of discipline
and they have a sense of their
masculinity but it end ends in them
transcending ultimately the
physical the physical aspect of of just
of just their their bodies and the same
with nuns too like if you look at
traditions of nuns how they would get
married with Christ like there's this
very feminine aspect of how how nuns
would exist in their in their monastic
life but in the same way they're called
to transcend the so so it's different
from the way we think about it now which
is you hear people now talk about
transcending gender but what they the
image of that is a confused gender right
it's like a hermaphroditic idea but
there's a difference between mixture and
Transcendence those are not the same
right that's a good way of putting it um
and you know this idea of The Cloud of
Unknowing above the waters above and the
waters below I think that's a really
helpful framework this is kind of an
aside for the discussion of
psychedelics yeah exactly right there's
a way of opening up to the beyond the
Unseen in a way that dis integrates the
Mind actually and and then there's a way
of transcending into the to the Mystic
the cloud above uh that does not
disintegrate uh the mind but is a proper
Ascent where we do not uh turn over
um I don't want to say the word control
because I don't mean control but uh full
integration of the Consciousness yeah
and CS Lewis has a really great image of
that you know in the great divorce for
example where he represents Heaven as
hyperreal in some ways right it's like
he's not he doesn't have this kind of
floating thing it's as if the more you
transcend the identity the realer it
actually becomes it's not a it's not a
it's not a kind that's what that's the
difference between Christianity and some
forms of mys ISM which is that we don't
believe that as we are united with God
that we lose our our our uniqueness but
rather the the fact that we are unique
creatures in God becomes more and more
bright as we come closer to the light
that made us and so and I think that se
Lewis some of the images he has in the
great divorce are really powerful to
they're obviously they're they're
they're imagistic you know we have have
to be careful how serious we take them
even he warns us about that in the great
divorce but you know this idea of like
the blade of grass that cuts right like
the sense that that reality that the
colors are so intense and that the the
reality is so solid that it would that
it's almost dangerous to a normal person
because of how real it is right it's it
Lewis loves to play with flipping things
on its head uh which I believe he really
gets from Dante right this is Dante
esque um so Dante uh you know in the
medieval cosmology and you talked about
this with Richard Roland in your last
podcast there's the Earth is at the
bottom this you know the center but is a
bottom and then as you move out from
Earth at Mount Purgatory through Eden up
into the heavens out into uh the third
heaven which would be the the throne
room and Abode of God what happens and
when Dante finally gets there is that
the whole Cosmos flips inside out and
all of a sudden the the The Throne of
God the the revelation of Christ the the
the Yellow Rose of the the church is the
center
and Earth is the
periphery Earth is the outside and it's
this kind of spatial inversion which I
think Lewis loved and that he saw it
also in Plato right where we think these
material things are the most real but
they're really in a sense shadows in the
cave and as we move out toward God and
toward reality there's a reversal and
those are the really solid firm things
and so Lewis has always I think he
really felt that the modern imagination
had been inverted and he's continually
working to try and flip the way that
we're understanding uh understanding
things um yeah maybe go ahead maybe you
can tell talk a bit about that because
you you said that the whole trilogy is
also modeled after in your impression
like it does model after the Divine
Comedy and so it's something that I
didn't perceive as as simply maybe you
can tell us how you see that yeah so the
first book out of Planet opens with a
pedestrian in midlife on a journey in a
dark wood right and so you always want
to pay attention to the opening the
beginning and so you know Lewis Here is
very much evoking the archetype of the
every man on a journey and you know it
also hearkens to um Pilgrim's Progress
but I I think it also alludes to Dante
um but rather than starting in hell and
then progressing to through Purgatory up
to Eden Eden's at the top of purgatory
right and then into the heavens I think
what you have is a three book structure
that reverses it is Lewis takes his hero
his Pilgrim into heaven first and then
from the heavens a vision of the heavens
he moves to paralandra which is really
Paradise it's a new Eden
right which would be at the top of
purgatory and then from that Eden he
descends to hell and most by the time we
get to That Hideous Strength most
Scholars recognize the dantesque
illusion and imagery um there's one
scholar David Downing who actually
thinks that the um antagonists who
participate in the nce are actually
revealed to us in order of the circles
of hell
and so you start with kind of The
Virtuous pagans who would be like the
the best Scholars but they're kind of
inept and ineffective but and then
you're moving and moving and moving
until you get I mean think about this
the treacherous are the worst and
they're the ones literally munched on by
the mouth of Satan yeah okay well how
are the treacherous punished at the end
of That Hideous Strength and the you've
got this false head we talked about yeah
and then they're munched on by I think
the bear right so that there the animals
come in and and and eat them basically
yeah right so I really do think you have
that kind of a a retelling of the Divine
Comedy but in a way that's inverted for
a world that's become inverted right so
when Dante was writing he could assume
that his readers knew what heaven was
that they believed in a heaven that they
that they understood there's a highest
good at which we aim and if that can be
assumed
then I can start by talking about Sin by
the way we miss the Mark we we miss that
highest Transcendent aim but modern we
don't believe in a highest aim we don't
believe in that highest good or that
Heavenly aim and so then we don't
understand what sin is because to turn
one way is just as good as to turn
another and so you know what I think
Lewis realized he need to begin with if
he's going to tr uh seeking to revive a
renewed understanding of a sacramental
or symbolic world is he has to start
with what was obvious to everybody
there's a heaven and so he starts his
Pilgrim by taking him into the heavens
and baptizing his imagination where he
expects to find the emptiness the alien
hostility of space instead he discovers
the beauty the Ecstasy of the heavens
and the light and the glory and the joy
so that's my proposal for how the ransom
Trilogy is a retelling of of Dante's
Divine Comedy but with a flipped
structure for a flipped world I mean
that when you say it I yeah I think
that's right I had I hadn't totally
understood it because I was not seeing
the structure but now if you if you flip
it and you see that that's exactly what
happens because he goes to he goes to to
Eden uh you know and then even in the
second book he goes down into like hell
it's weird like he goes out he has he
has a little like goes down to Hell and
then he goes up the mountain and then he
comes up to the to the marriage between
Adam and Eve ultimately like at the at
the end of the of the book uh and he has
that kind of basic structure in there as
well but if you think of the whole
structure like that um yeah yeah that
makes that that makes a lot of sense um
and so one of the there there there are
a few more things that I'm that I'm
questioning one of the things that
really shocked me a little bit and in
some ways it what made me write the made
that video on the subtle bodies was the
way in which he describes the Angels you
know and and and it's like I think that
I have to I have to be careful because I
think it is also possible that we have
to see it from within the subc created
world right we have to see it from
within the world that he tried to create
but because so so just so people
listening know what I mean is that he
describes the subtle bodies of the
Angels really as kind of like made of
light or made of this translucent
material um and and because we have
Ghostbusters right because we have like
Slimer that you can kind of see through
and but then he leaves a trace of slime
all over where he's going and we have
this but csis would have known about
ectoplasm and about Edgar case and about
this idea of subtle the way that subtle
bodies were interpreted as just
basically material bodies that are less
that are that are less physical but are
still physical in that weird way uh I
was a little worried about the way he
described those bodies because I felt
like like it could lead people to a kind
of misunderstanding about what it is
that we're talking about when we talk
about these subtle bodies so I don't
know if you had thoughts on that yeah I
I do because I I really see what you're
saying and so I did a little bit of
research and I found a letter that Lewis
wrote to children so one thing I love
about him is he people wrote him all the
time and he did his best to respond to
everybody even to Children And so
there's a collection of Louis's letters
to children that you can get that are
really delightful so some children wrote
to him about angels and his portray of
angels and here's what he said to them
the view that angels have no bodies of
any kind has not always been held among
Christians the old idea early Middle
Ages was that they had bodies of ether
as we have bodies of gross matter the
opposite view your view was one of the
Great scol Plastics Albert Magnus Thomas
aquinus Etc of course I just took for
the purposes of a story that one that
seemed most imaginable so I think this
is what you're saying well within a
story story is like poetry it uses the
forms that sensory images in order to
construct meaning so in a sense that's
what you have to have work in that sense
I get like I totally agree because it's
like after I made that critique I was
thinking about it myself it's like I
just published a graphic novel with with
a with a man with the head of a dog you
know and it's like you know and so I
don't and so I also I don't think that
St Christopher you know had was the
descendant of a canine you know it's
like I don't think that but I think the
best way to represent whatever he was
and the whever he presented himself was
is that way uh because he's a monster in
some ways and so it's like so then after
that I I realized I'm being critical to
CS Lewis and the same critique could be
applied to me which is like or did he
really believe that St Christopher is
like a is a half man half dog in the in
the kind of gross sense you know right
and so and so so so then I I kind of I
kind of so I think you're I think even
reading that letter helps me to see that
he he he definitely had a a
sophisticated understanding that he was
representing in a story yeah well
there's a little bit more there's more
of the quote though okay go for it yeah
so um I mean this part of the difficulty
is we see right now but through a cloud
Darkly we the only way we experience
Heaven is through its
manifestation right in the visible um
okay so he says I have no Scruples about
this because religiously the question
seems to me of no importance I gotta
think about that more I'm not sure the
questions of no importance but then
here's his last line anyway what do we
mean by
matter so that's what I find really
interesting and and kind of what I was
playing with and wondering and kind of
wondering what you think this is just
testing a theory is that Lewis more than
trying to use like say ectoplasm or I
think he was kind of trying to tap into
images that come from quantum theory
okay that because there's one passage
where he's talking about you know the
difference I think it's one of the sorns
who are like the philosophers and out of
the Silent Planet he talks about speed
and so we experience these things is
solid because we live at a slower level
whereas the a elila they they they move
so
quickly and I I might be getting this
wrong but some of what I wonder is you
know Lewis was an idealist before he
became a Christian okay so he's gonna be
he's G to be maybe biased towards an
idealist understanding which which is
opposite of the materialist so rather
than dragging the Angels down to the
level of the material I wonder if he's
playing with the idea in light of
quantum theory of the fact that what is
matter anyway isn't it all form
elevating matter into the realm of form
just slowed down yeah yeah does that
make sense maybe yeah that that that
that that is that is possible and but I
think it's funny because now when you
talk about this whole discussion on
speed and stuff again it's like I'm kind
of cringing of I cringe a little bit
about those types of discussions and
it's mostly because my own I think it's
because of my own allergy of yeah of of
when I when I grew up you know I was in
a world where people were trying to
constantly give scientific explanations
for for the Bible and for Spiritual
things and they ended up
just constantly stepping in massive
holes that they could never that they
couldn't dig themselves out of and
that's why like I always worry about
people who talk about that Quantum stuff
because it's like you don't know what
that stuff is and that stuff's meant to
change at any moment and so if you make
your your description like descriptions
of things based on that uh you are
you're I know you're in some you're a
little bit of in danger you know it's
like I remember people tell me things
like angels are another dimensions and I
was like what the hell are you talking
about like you mean that scientifically
are you sure you wanna you want to push
down that road like are you sure that's
what you want uh but anyway so I mean I
I have to say like I those are the
little parts of that that trilogy that
we're kind of ah I didn't I I struggle
with but you know obviously CS Lewis was
was clearly had Insight amazing Insight
the last thing I I want to bring up with
you and ask you what you think about is
the whole Merlin situation you know that
is a that I think of of the in the That
Hideous Strength is to me the most
fascinating part of the story which is
how CS Lewis perceives Merlin as a
character and the way that he uses
trickery like you know I've kind of
joked about this idea a of the the the
trickster or the Joker you know the fool
that that brings the king back it's
something that mat talks about also
quite a bit in his thinking but it seems
like CS Lewis did that in the book where
he brings back this very strange figure
to kind of bring about even more chaos
which then which then sets things right
so I don't know if you thought about
Merlin in the in
that yeah it's it is one of the more
controversial part parts of the book and
one that I don't feel as that I have my
head around as confidently as I do maybe
say the way he's using gender but I I do
think the best way that I understand it
is if you go back in time so Lewis was
very influenced by Owen Barfield right
and I even think that idea of speed that
he is getting that from barfield's
poetic diction and um um saving the
appearances where barfield's Theory
basically is is in the beginning we
perceived things as
holes so whereas now as moderns we we
separate the thing and the meaning the
sign and the meaning whereas
in maybe our original Unity we
experience thing and meaning as the same
and Lewis he alludes to this in the
language so he there's this old solar
language which Merlin speaks which
Ransom learns and it's he says it's pure
language itself it's where the sounds
and the the words themselves are not
like our words
are lar arbitrarily connected to the
meaning right old solar is where you
basically speak pure symbolic language
and he talks about how the words fall
like great Stones you know just a really
beautiful passage and so that earlier on
our Consciousness was a unity and it it
started to separate right subject and
object started to separate I start to
know my thing as separate I we start to
separate everything and you know for
barfield's theory of language this is
kind of you talk about this that that
was an inevitable yeah but that the way
forward is a reuniting and I really do
think think this is important in Lewis's
vision is that you know the old
sacramental view of the
world uh was full of meaning and purpose
and order and it and you talk about this
it's still phenomenologically true it's
still the way we experience the world
phenomenologically okay now we have this
objective way of knowing through science
and Analysis and coming from the outside
and we feel like they're at odds but
they're not they're not at odds odds
because Christ the logos in him all
things hold together all you know and
that uh and this is David Bentley's
heart and Beauty David Bentley heart's
argument in beauty of the infinite which
is phenomenal I think the best answer to
postmodernism I've ever read except it's
almost unreadable for most people so we
really need someone to do a popular
version of this book but you know
because it's all love and
grace the logos guaranteeing and
creating so that our subjective
meaningful experience of the world fits
together with the objective way that the
world is structured that the logos in me
resonates with the logos in the world
and that there is a connection these do
fit together so Barfield and Lewis
thought that okay our we we had an
original Unity where we didn't and they
separated and then that's going to it's
a little bit hegelian give us a greater
synthesis where we're able to know both
the subjective and the objective and
reunite them in a a a a a higher level
Unity of of being and perception and
Barfield talks about that in terms of
speed he kind of imagines and and so not
speed maybe a physical motion but speed
of perception that and this would be the
higher Consciousness where our our speed
of perception is able to know both and
integrate them at the same at the same
time so that's the way I understood
Lewis looking at um this idea of speed
that the angels have that higher their
their speed of perception and
being whereas ours is slower and we
experience thing as separates um so but
then to to connect to Merlin right so
his idea that as the world is moving
from this original Unity towards
separation um Merlin stands at kind of a
transition point
and
that that in that process of
Separation there would be
unities between humanity and
nature that we're not
elicit but that as we've become as we've
started to see ourselves objectively and
separate from nature have become
elicit and so and this is just the idea
that he's playing with and he talks
about one of his characters say that as
the world you think of this in terms of
your idea of the center and the margin
the world in history in sense in a sense
unfolds this way we began with a primal
unity in in Eden and as history is
moving forward there's a a fragmentation
and a separation that is
happening um and
that so he's bringing back Merlin from a
a point in that process where he could
still enact a certain task that has
become illegitimate for US based on
where we are at in the unfolding of
History history all to say I do think
it's
speculative um and you know in a world
fascinated by the
occult I feel like this is you know
similar to the the problems people have
with uh like Harry Potter right she's
playing
with um certain ideas and and Powers uh
in a way that with our world who who is
fascinated with the idea of tapping into
the cloud of knowing
below can be maybe misleading or
confusing
yeah one of one of the things about
Merlin that were fascinating to me was
you know I like I had read I had read
that a long time ago like in my early 20
even I think late teens early 20s and so
there were some parts of it I didn't
remember and so rereading it now that
Merlin part really stood out for me
because I am I'm working on rewriting uh
a story which is in the Merlin
legendarium it's a it's a romance called
silence where there's I did a video
about it but in that in that story
Merlin appears and Merlin is the one
that restores order in the end but the
way that he does it is through laughter
he laughs he laughs he mocks everything
he laughs at everything and he laughs at
all these things that look like scandals
or that look like you shouldn't be
laughing at them you know like let's say
a funeral or or some tragedy or some
Beggars and he just laughs at them and
at the end he kind of reveals the secret
of why he's laughing for them and what
it does is it restores everything in its
proper place and there's something about
and I was wondering like if first of all
seef lus had read that text but then I
realized that it's there also in other
texts like in Jeffrey monmouth's uh poem
about Merlin where Merlin kind of plays
that trickster role but a trickster that
that restores the the world in the end
through a kind of yeah through and and
that's what happens in in the Hideous
Strength because he all because there
are some narrative tropes that he that
he uses that he weren't necessary but
that are almost there to kind of bring
confusion to a Brink where Merlin is
there in the in their in the ni but he's
actually not him he brings someone else
and that person is Merlin but he's the
other guy that is the translator but the
translator is actually Merlin and so
there's this like everything is is
confused and the appear Nothing Is What
It Seems uh and then through that he
brings about like the liberation of
Nature and the kind of the return of
this he almost brings about a kind of
flood basically that destroys the the ni
and so it's kind of weird it's
fascinating because he because in some
way CS swis presents Merlin he says that
great Atlantean magic which that is like
that's Cod that's code word for pre
flood like pre flood world and so he's a
remainder of the pref flood world and
that in some ways plays the role of what
those ancient magicians would have done
which is to bring about a flood right
think about like the idea of the
Nephilim of the Giants like their
excessive magic and their kind of weird
uh Science and Technology basically
brought the flood about we don't know
exactly how but they that's how it
brought about the flood and so Merlin
does that but to the good ultimately
it's weird like it's this whole weird
flip thing where he brings about
basically flood but it's to the
Salvation of the of the world so I I
just thought like it was such a profound
story Trope uh and I and I was like how
did he I mean I guess he was reading
also all these medieval these medieval
texts um but I was really surprised to
see because it does sound controversial
but it seems to me that there's
something about it which is if we're
gonna bring the world back to if we're
gonna make everything make sense in the
end and everything is going to come
together then it's like he undoes the
pre flood World uses it to basically
solve the problem of the end of the
world and then brings about the final
marriage like the final Heavenly
Jerusalem anyways I'm still thinking
about this but I was really surprised
that how
how how insightful his use of Merlin was
because it doesn't it seems weird like
it's so surpris like why is mlin in this
space Trilogy of all things right it
just looks like a like a at first you're
like what is this random weird thing
that it's like starts with the science
fiction thing in space and it ends with
like a sorcerer destroying the this
weird secret society but I think I think
yeah I think those he had very deep
insights about how things play out right
well that connects to what you're saying
about the AI you know what we think that
science again the Tower of Babel is
raising up science is building up powers
that we think come from science but then
when the mask is revealed there's powers
and principalities at work behind so I
love the way that he uses science
fiction as a genre genre to you know he
thought it was the the Locust in the
modern world where the imagination was
still
open right where there was still an
openness to Discovery to new and so he
uses that genre again to you know to
he's always flipping things on its head
to
return you to an openness to powers and
principalities and spiritual Powers um
and I agree with you the first time I
read it I thought what is going on it
took me several reads and and I think
everything you're describing makes a lot
of sense and I just need it's just a
part I haven't meditated on but you do
note Merlin is a big man so in terms of
that connection to Atlantis and to the
Nephilim he is portrayed as a giant but
he's also he's not he's not clean he's
dangerous like he's he's like why don't
you kill I think he he he he like
proposes to like kill like whatever
transgression like and he's just like
he's like this wild dangerous thing that
you don't really want around you but
that ultimately ends
up and and but it makes me think a
little bit because you know this whole
tradition of Merlin being the son of the
devil or being the son of the dragon or
something uh it makes me think about
something the father step D young has
helped me to understand something I've
had intuition about for a long time
which is how the church fathers talk
about how the demons ultimately without
knowing they're end they're gonna end up
playing a role
in service of God it's not we're not
justifying them we're not saying that
they're right and that what they're
doing is good but that God is in God is
ultimately in control and and through a
mysterious way that they play the left
hand of God right they kind of without
even wanting to they end up playing this
role in Divine Providence that will end
up bringing about you know the final
restoration um and it's like it just
seems like Lewis
had insights about that like very deep
insight about that and that's why at
first when you read it you're like why
is Merlin in this thing and then slowly
it starts playing but I I haven't
figured it out completely I'm still you
can see I'm still working through it
right now but I think there's something
there are things to be meditated upon
and how he uses this character in that
way right I love what you say about
laughter because very much in the
medieval world you know you had a very
well-ordered world right and and all
things were to be in harmony with the
the the
the order of the cosmos um the song of
the cosmos and we're to live in that
order and in that Harmony but things you
know because we're fallen and things get
out of order they get out of tune they
get distorted out of proportion and for
the medieval that's what laughter does
is it pokes that Distortion it pokes
that disorder and and and that's
actually a kind gracious way to bring
back humility and order to that which
had become disproportionate Out Of Tune
and and I just I love that view of
laughter I very much you know raising my
own girls we talk about the importance
of being able to laugh at yourself and
that being able to laugh at yourself is
the gentlest way to become aware of you
know your weaknesses and and um and so I
love that Merlin plays this you know div
so he has this interesting figure and
and I wonder okay so he Lewis is using
Merlin to look at how do we deal with
the end end of the world chaos where all
is moving towards confusion where things
are turned upside down and so you very
much do have that uh doppelganger like
that uh um shadow figure you again I
love Harry Potter snake plays this role
you can never tell if he's good or bad
yeah yeah yeah that's right right until
the end and and ring also does this
where it's actually Voldemort's own
spell that kills him right where it's
it's actually playing that trickster so
as to allow chaos to um collapse in on
itself yeah that's what that's
definitely what you see in That Hideous
Strength it's basically it's like you
know everything the Nic basically like
just collapses on its own in its own
thing and there is this return of nature
you know the the idea of the animals
coming it really is a flood uh although
I think it there's mostly fire in the
when how it's destroyed but it is that
imagy of like just nature it's like if
you if you distort reality nature comes
back howling like you can't distort
natural order long to for too long at
some point it comes back and when it
comes back it's it's not going to be
nice to you you know and that just
that's is that's is true about something
as big as the ni in this story but it's
also true that if you decide to eat junk
food all the time like you if you if you
try to distort order for too long it's
like some point you're reality comes
crashing back you know and that's
something that I that that I see very
powerfully and it it fits with cs
Lewis's basic idea about how in some
ways hell is Led from the inside and how
you know in the great divorce he he's
has the most powerful vision of how hell
is basically you getting what you want
uh and that you know um and so and that
it's not just this arbitrary thing but
it's just a playing out of the of the of
the of the patterns that you're involved
so yeah right you which you see with the
the antagonist and That Hideous Strength
where what they wanted was to turn
themselves over to the macrobes the
Demonic Powers you know and and that
that's what they get but it's revealed
for what it is right which is a collapse
into you know total total disintegration
and you know what I I do think you know
when we think about Merlin and um those
end of the world spaces um at the margin
and the confusion and the chaos how do
we live there what I wonder is you know
I don't know that we're being offered I
don't know so I really want to know what
you think I don't know that we're being
offered Merlin as a model for our own I
don't think so I think I think I don't
think so I think that I think maybe it's
the role of some people to play that to
play that but I think mostly if you look
at the way it's set up it's like the
people uh you know the the people on
Ransom side they basically just wait
like they they they basically keep them
themselveses pure you could say they
they they work you know they stay
together they help each other they they
kind of create this little world of of
of Holiness and then it's like it'll
play out Merlin basically will do what
he has to do and he ends up working for
us without us totally understanding why
and it ends up happening and so I think
that you know I think that it is the
role of some people to to play that but
Merlin is destroyed also by the way in
that in that act he's not he's not saved
you
know right yeah so I definitely think
Ransom and his community is the model
and you know to to live Faithfully yeah
in natural communities right they they
properly husband and Steward their
Garden their nature they have rightly
ordered relationship with themselves and
they Faithfully wait for the Salvation
of the Lord to appear and like you're
saying you know some someone might be
called to be the Merlin figure but woe
is me I mean it's not it's not good for
Merlin doesn't end well for him and that
story basically runs to his own
destruction yeah so maybe that's how he
save but still nonetheless that's what
happens you know yeah all right well
Annie this has been a great conversation
and uh I want to encourage everybody to
look into the description you will find
a way to to either uh sign up for her
class or at least get put on a waiting
list so that once everything all the the
details are set up you can sign up and
uh look forward to more of these we're
you know we're trying to really bolster
the symbolic World Community we've got
some we're just discovering all these
these pearls and these amazing people
that are part of it that want to get
involved so you can also get involved by
signing up on the website and Annie
thanks thanks for all your effort thanks
for the article and thanks for putting
so much of your heart into this yeah
thank you Jonathan this has been really
fun hey everyone thank you for listening
to my conversation with Jonathan if you
want to join in and continue the
discussion follow the link in the
episode notes to sign up for our
symbolic world class on CS Lewis's
Ransom Trilogy we are about to wrap up
paralandra but there is still time to
jump in For That Hideous Strength when
you sign up you'll receive access to all
our recorded discussions of out of the
Silent Planet and paralandra and then
you can join us through the rest of
October and November for live
discussions every Friday uh at 3 pm
Central 4M eastern time this class has
been fantastic because Lewis is a genius
and the people at the symbolic World
Community are truly wonderful wise
thoughtful insightful kind and generous
you will not find a class like this
anywhere else so follow that link in the
episode notes you won't want to miss it